[Music]
77% of prisoners released in America
will be back behind bars within five
years reoffending is one of the biggest
problems facing justice systems around
the world and nowhere is this more
apparent than in America a country that
has a quarter of all the world's
prisoners but can wild horses help you
don't feel caged anymore
[Music]
definitely I feel like the horses hang
with me sometimes these men are
prisoners and horse whisperers they
teach you a lot about relationships
about hard work perseverance patience
[Music]
at Arizona State Prison
the inmates trade their handcuffs for
horses the emerging to tame wild
mustangs as part of a rehabilitation
program since it was introduced
reoffending rates amongst those who have
completed the program have fallen to 4
percent over the last five years
Mustangs have been a part of the
American West since it since it began
the horses in the wild though that are
on Bureau of Land Management lands are
protected but when wild Mustang herds
grow too big they struggle to find
enough food and can damage the local
ecosystem to keep the population under
control around six thousand have rounded
up each year most end up in government
holding pens at a cost of around forty
nine million dollars annually but some
are broken in and sold on through horse
whispering programs like this one
we care for house and try to get horses
adopted out my name is Anthony Anthony
garrison and my horse name is flex I'm
in prison for burglary and drugs I've
been in since 2010 I don't get out till
February of 2021 my name is Toby and and
the horse's name is Clyde from Bonnie
and Clyde I I'm in for drug possession
and I've been in for four and a half
years four and a half years for simple
possession six and a half since the
1970s successive US government's have
encouraged the harshest punishment for
some offenses including mandatory
minimum sentences for drug-related
crimes this has seen the prison
population balloon 500% in 50 years
this program is a drop in the ocean
helping only a small number of inmates
but it's an imaginative solution to help
solve the rehabilitation problem in
American prisons the incarceration issue
in in America it's obviously huge and
the difficulty is to programs like this
are really really not that easy to to
develop the aim of the wild mustang
program is to teach prisoners life
skills that will prevent them from
reoffending in the long run this will
keep the prison population down if we
can reach a handful of inmates and they
don't really not just a monetary saving
but you have a person who has now become
a productive part of society the untamed
animals show many similar traits to the
inmates and the wild these horses are
primarily focused on survival one of the
guys have come into prison have this
kind of same mindset there are so many
parallels to what what the horse goes
doing what the inmate goes through the
inmate has to learn
how to live different they have learned
how to think different the basic
principle is you make the wrong thing
harder to doing the right thing easier
to do of the 50 inmates who have been
released after completing the program
only to have returned to prison the
inmates start taking responsibility for
something beyond themselves
rehabilitation programs like this could
help break the cycle of reoffending I'm
just not the same person I was when I
first came down I don't think the same I
don't act the same I don't react the
same it's taught me to help me with
being selfless this job isn't about me
this job is about this horse right here
as I've give up my time my patience and
my energy I'm the one who's actually
being taught the lessons pioneering
programs like this a time-consuming hard
to establish and can only help a small
number of inmates but they're effective
bucking the trend of reoffending
you